a month ago they stopped issuing ammunition to us
and we receive no more than ten
percent,
we were going to take possession of the Bakmut settlement by May 9, 23,
but when they saw it, the
military bureaucrats
actually stopped any supplies from May 1
to prevent us from doing this because
they are sitting shaking their fat bellies  And they
think that they will go down in history as
winners, they have already entered it as cowards
to carry losses in bakhmut without ammunition,
useless unjustified
my guys will not be,
therefore,
from May 10, 23, we
leave the village banged,
we have to take two and a half
kilometers 45
But if for a reason  your petty envy,
you don't want to give victory
to the Russians by taking it.
These are your problems